Too many mussels can make for a sticky situation.
Mussels are marine biofoulers,
like barnacles and seaweed.
They’ll take any opportunity to
attach themselves to an object.
They can clog pipes,
destroy scientific equipment,
and damage dams and boats.
Researchers have spent decades
trying to prevent mussels
from attaching to everything they encounter.
Now they've developed a polymer lubricant
that prevents the mussels from attaching to
underwater surfaces.
The key to the mussel’s stickiness is byssal thread,
a sticky fiber the animal secretes
as soon as it detects a solid structure.
The new lubricant repels organic matter
so the scientists hypothesized that it would
prevent the mussel from noticing the surface
beneath them and initiating attachment.
In testing, an asian green mussel
poked its sticky appendage out at the surface…
but it couldn’t grab hold, the coating worked!
The coating also worked In the field.
After 8 weeks of submersion, plates coated
with the polymer only averaged
4 mussels per square centimeter.
The control averaged 118.
There is still testing to be done before
this anti-mussel material will reach the market.
But for scientists and sailors alike,
it could be a life-saver.